jedes mädchen träumt davon einmal schön
und berühmt zu sein
doch dieser traum probleme einer
lifestyle bürgerin heute outfit of the
day macht er jetzt endlich das foto
meine wand tun schon voll weh und ich
muss voll pinkeln warum bin ich dann
vorhin nicht gegangen und in einen busch
gehe ich ganz sicher nicht gleichwertig
warum es im februar sucht halt er ist
das eklig hey das ist auch nicht besser
man ist das widerlich bis mittag etwas
lang gelaufen
bitte nicht eine spinne bestimmt eine
ganz fette spinne einfach weiter lächeln
ja ja ist das schön ihr alter weiß denn
nicht wo der auslöser ist oder was ich
wette ich habe da ein problem sagt es
mir nicht seiner hose eigentlich fett
aus der beim anziehen schon wehgetan und
zweck mich die ganze zeit vorne und
hinten sowieso mein arsch ist so fett
geworden
jetzt hab ich mir das eingeklemmt
einfach lächeln hat keiner gesehen
ich bringe nur einfach tot und dann
vergraben im wald wo ich glaube ich muss
diesen ich glaube ich muss ich muss
jedoch nicht einfach ins licht
doch nicht
ich habe gesagt dass ich ihn umbringen
dort immer da war ja wirklich an opel
so fertig was denkst du das war's wie
das war's und dann bringt sie ihn um
ernsthaft wirst du die idee nicht gut
nicht wirklich dann machst du es doch
besser und springe deiner fantasie ich
kann keine videos produzieren ja stimmt
auch wieder dann also wirst du das jetzt
hochladen
ich weiß nicht jetzt hast du mich
irgendwie verunsichert
es ist mein job dich zu verunsichern ich
bin deine innere stimme heißt es etwa du
liegst gerade nicht wirklich auf meiner
couch in spiels gameboy doch na klar
aber doch nur in deiner fantasie deshalb
kann ich auch dass hier kaum jetzt mit
albern deshalb durchbreche ich die
vierte wand und sprache direkt mit dem
zuschauer
ich hoffe dir das video gefallen und
dass wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder
sehen
kkk ach ja passt dies vergessen schaut
mal bei micro minsky auf dem kanal wenn
ihr euch für tipps und tricks zum thema
fotografie film und der ganzen
bearbeitungs geschichten interessiert
der macht richtig coole videos zu dem
thema ich guck regelmäßig bei ihm und
schaue mir ein bisschen was ab wenn ich
mal was etwas besser bearbeiten möchte
also gebt mal auf seinen kanal lasten
schönen gruß da und wir sehen uns